there has long been talk of Hal Berry
going to extraordinary links to get into
character as Vivien alongside Samuel
Jackson in Jungle Fever Spike Le's 1991
exploration of romance and race
relations Jackson portrayed the scene
stealing drug addled brother of Wesley
Snipes lead character named Gator while
Barry was Gator's Hard Scrabble main
squeeze jungle fever features a
memorable scene that called for Jackson
and Barry to bicker back and forth when
Gator wants some alone time with his
brother for Barry who came from the
world of modeling it was an unexpected
role and one she had worked hard to land
to prepare for the part she spent
several weeks not bathing with most
reports claiming that she went unwashed
for 2 weeks in 2012 the Oscar winner
told talk show host Wendy Williams that
the method tale was no exaggeration
claiming to have avoided bathing for
about 10 days she said it's true ask Sam
Jackson he had to get a whiff of it
constantly